it's very simple adults have to be
adults again
my mom and daddy were the adults in the
house and when my dad sat me down at the
age of 15 on the steps of his home 661
Kennesaw Avenue Northeast Atlanta
Georgia 30308
404-874-2836 he told me at the age of 15
that there's no greater honor than to
wear the uniform in the United States of
America now this is a man that was born
in the south in 1920.
and that's what he felt this was a man
that went and fought for his country in
World War II when this country did not
recognize him as being equal to others
but that's what he told me he challenged
me to be the first officer in the family
because he said I want you to be better
and more than what I was how old were
you at the time 15 and so what did I
start off with I start out in High
School Junior ROTC Grady High School
Atlanta Georgia and then I went on to
University of Tennessee on 31 July 1982
the only time I ever saw my dad with
tears in his eyes the day that he penned
on second Lieutenant bars it's amazing